we do start talking to these companies
earlier and we start looking and using
our tools actually you know once you
have four five quarters of growth under
your belt that's where our
tools would work best right or better
welcome to 20 minute leaders just sit
back relax and learn from the leaders of
today it's a journey each one is
different unique inspiring let's get
started
[Music]
this episode is powered by jay ventures
a community driven vc fund in silicon
valley in partnership with lumitec
sponsored by homeward ventures hippo
insurance oppos labs synergy global
hillel at stanford leap birthright excel
serona partners and in media partnership
with ctec
welcome to another episode of 20 minute
leaders today i'm honored to be here
with my friend the guy horowitz guy is a
partner at dtcp in the growth equity
team in silicon valley
dai led dtcp's investments in replay
technologies acquired by intel fire
glass acquired by symantec and dynamic
yield acquired by mcdonald's he also led
ddcp's investments in safe breach morphe
sec appsflyer and perimeter x and
represents it as a board member and
observer
guy horowitz welcome to 20 minute
leaders how are you not too bad i mean
new york city i mean we're not in here
so we're in the empire state building
actually right now uh this is such a
pleasure to have you here i've been such
a big fan of your work not of your
investments although they're incredible
investments i've been a fan of your of
your music work oh wow and your songs
and we'll talk a little bit about your
band and i want to understand a little
bit about what you do in silicon valley
just besides investments and then
connecting it to
the daily work but also your ability to
translate your thoughts
about the world about the things that
are happening in the context into music
in a way that thousands of people
truly enjoy listening and engaging with
it i think that's that's a beautiful
thing so thank you for entertaining me
and for enriching my life over the last
year and a half during the pandemic and
guy tell me a little bit about yourself
sure so born and raised in israel
um spent a few years here in the u.s
actually across the bridge in new jersey
which helped shape who i am i went back
to do military service in israel like
many israelis do
and my dream and my uh ambition was to
come back here and do business uh
unfortunately or fortunately life
decided for me that i was gonna stay in
israel to help build a few companies
startups back in the 90s i'm older than
the city um and uh yeah then went on to
build startups in the 90s he said yeah
so i was part of a startup back in 98 it
was doing basically like a whatsapp
before whatsapp firstly the apps world
did not exist at the time so we had to
sell to carriers wow and if there's
anything i learned over my uh history
and my career is that you don't want to
work with carriers certainly worked with
them and for them for about
10 years of my life
um
because i learned fast
so
2004 joined a great vc in israel called
gemini uh and spent five years there um
the legend uh gemini's now a legend at
the time it was not as obvious as it is
right now in the hindsight it's 20 20 or
20 20 months
so um i we spent a few years helping
companies get to the next stage i
actually you know rolled up my sleeves
as they say or whatever the right term
is and join a few of our own portfolio
companies in different uh executive
roles which was great uh also worked for
microsoft for a short bit take me just
one second in the 90s when you're when
you're in the tech ecosystem well it was
it's for me it's trivial you know 2021
i'm 25 years old that's my life this is
what's around me this is what's sexy is
it
is it the same feeling that it was in
the 90s there was something pioneering
and again that's that's a weird thing my
dad was in high tech in the 70s right so
wow yeah but for me i started college
school in 92 we had computers all over
and i went to do military service where
we had zero computers only binoculars so
i felt 96 i felt like i missed the train
right i was back
in tech or you know back in the world
and everyone was already kind of
literate and i was illiterate so for me
it was kind of a catch-up race and i
think everyone felt this thing is going
to change the world but not necessarily
in the same way we think of it today
right it's going to change our lives as
individuals not necessarily how
companies do business so it took a while
before we realized by my first startup
we did a direct to consumer
e-learning thing like gmat prep
and we ended up selling that to a b2b
type entity that was selling this to
businesses so the world took this shift
towards b2b and i was just there at the
right time
um but again i didn't feel like we're
doing anything super significant i'm
just having a lot of fun traveling
trotting the globe what have you um so
you know
year 2012 i was offered to run a local
outspot or outpost for a german company
called deutsche telekom i heard a little
bit about them yeah they're tiny own
t-mobile and such right
so again that was great because i could
run a local
shop we had r d we had business
development a little bit of venturing
going i was frustrated as anyone doing
ventures with or for a corporate would
be frustrated uh express those
perspectives to the ceos of the company
of deutsche telekom and just fortunately
someone else in the organization was
thinking along the same lines we ended
up you know doing this thing called dtcp
which started as a single lp fund now
it's a multi-lb fund but it's completely
the opposite of what a corporate venture
is or how you think of it right you're
incredible you want to make money yeah
definitely and so now you're investing
in some the some of the most brilliant
startups uh some of which
some of my best friends work at wow and
uh and it's really really great to see
and you're in the growth scene
and so you know incredible time to to do
investments but before we get into the
investment side of what you do with dtcp
tell me a little bit about a hobby that
you know you've really
i think you know it's
it's very engaging for me as a so as a
consumer to engage with your work uh you
know as an artist and as a musician and
it's very inspiring for me also to see
people that are that are so heavily
involved in the tech ecosystem you're
sitting on the boards of some of the
fastest growing companies and so i know
how busy that gets yet you make sure to
put in
you know time to for to fulfill you know
your inner passions tell me a little bit
about that right so first it's an outlet
right for everyone working tech or
working venture you need to have
something that's not just that race and
especially growth stage we're in sales
basically we're selling our money to
entrepreneurs we're doing super well
someone else might offer them that same
money for even cheaper so we need to
kind of you know relax and wind down
think of the future but also what we do
i mean i'm in a band in silicon valley
right and it's crazy because it's an
israeli event we're all kind of tech
people and ventures so you know very
specific types of people who gather in
on sundays to do rock and we do recover
right we don't do our own music
and if i think of it connected to my
world of venturing it's actually the
product market fit for covers especially
israeli covers
in silicon valley yeah is so much better
than my own music kind of my own you
know
which i i like but no one else would
want to listen to right so we found this
thing people want to listen to there are
not too many rock
people in silicon valley singing in
hebrew so
doing that actually allows me to enjoy
being suddenly even as a vc i'm chasing
companies and trying to shove my money
uh now they're actually coming to my
concerts our concerts and listening
that's awesome and i think also shows
that you know i could be an amazing
singer songwriter i'm not but had i been
a great one
people would have paid top dollar to to
see me and buy my records right
but in reality there are many such
people who do not get to the prime time
do not become unicorns or decacorns of
music right so sometimes product market
fit is as important if not more
important than being this brilliant kind
of singular
you know right snowflake
percent and so tell me a little bit
about that that sense of fulfillment
because i think that it's an interesting
for me it sounds like you're you're you
know you're practicing as an investor in
the day-to-day but then you're also an
entrepreneur within you know in terms of
the music and you're experiencing what
it's like to reach that product market
fit and to create a product that people
truly enjoy not just chasing this sort
of deep technology create your own music
for for for years or decades without
people really engaging with it right
right so i think it's another balance i
mean first
you know there's a day job and you got
to put your effort into that um but
there's also a uh let's call it a mix
you gotta have this mix of passion
and something that comes from the soul
and enters the soul rather than just the
monetary side i think that's true for
every startup or every business
definitely in venture capital you got to
have this mix gotta have this balance um
and for me personally i mean kovid you
know and and everything that happened
since was also a revelation because you
know there's facebook and other social
media where you can actually get to
people not necessarily through that you
know i want to sell tickets or sell you
know records or whatever the unit of
measure is for music nowadays right
singles uh it's actually through people
discovering you you know things being
kind of made viral through whatsapp and
whatnot and getting those calls and
those messages from people is actually
almost as satisfying and gratifying
especially if you have a day job that
pays well i mean if you need to make
your money from music good luck with
that but if you are able to
support yourself and then get all this
positive feedback on an individual basis
you know kind of michael writing me a
text that's way better than anything
else so i think having that in your
world would be highly recommended for
anyone who's doing anything intense well
i have to say that you know you're
you're a rock star in our in our world
like just from the music and and for me
you know i i got to do it i got to do
episodes with a lot of investors and a
lot of entrepreneurs i am truly excited
i feel like i'm talking to a celebrity
because i i'm sitting and i just love
the work that you're doing on on the
music side and all of a sudden in
preparation for this i'm looking at the
incredible investments that you've made
and the boards that you sit at and the
way that you think through the
investments and the thesis of of dtcp
and like wow this is so cool and and it
still dawns on me that what i still
truly care about is the is the musician
part of you tell me a little bit about
dtcp you're sitting on some great boards
what how do you sort of reason through
the you know the investment world today
okay so a lot has changed we started
2015 you know our thesis was always
enterprise sas we started with omnistage
and gradually kind of gravitated towards
the later stages i still you know
remember fondly the days where we could
invest in companies that had no revenue
i think now those days are gone
and but the world has also gone you know
into a different direction than we
thought i mean some companies we thought
of as hey great ideas that are doing
okay and they're going to do better
because
the companies that have great
um units of measure great kpis you know
the
kind of the top greatest uh criteria out
there are actually going to pro
outperform everyone and as investors we
want to be there so you look at our
portfolio today we're very kpi driven
and metrics driven and we have we've
built a tool and an analysis platform
that allows us to basically select the
top of the crop and go after those
statistically speaking we're not going
to be able to invest into each and every
one of them right but if we are able to
invest into
one of those it's going to do so much
better than your typical average
okay plus company that we just have to
focus on those so our platform and how
early how early do you do that for so
obviously you know companies are are
moving very very fast today right and
they're and they're raising roundups
around but how early do you go both in
terms of making the relationship with
the person so that they would want to
partner with you it's a two-way street
but also in terms of you be having
enough time to actually analyze and see
okay what is actually happening here
right so you know we started and we
gravitated very quickly towards the
leader what happened is that
it's getting harder and we need to start
looking earlier like everyone else right
we do not have the set of tools that
allows us to scale well in the three
kind of 10 million er
realm right so most of our companies
would be in the 10 15 millionaire or sar
because focused enterprise has right um
but we do start talking to these
companies earlier and start looking and
using our tools actually you know once
you have four five quarters of growth
under your belt that's where our
tools would work best right or better so
how do we work with companies earlier uh
we built this like and again this might
be a vc cliche but your value creation
team is probably the most important team
right in your organization because
that's a differentiator right yeah
that's a secret sauce so we and again
product market fit many of those
companies both in israel and here in the
us um are lacking in europe they're
they're lacking the ability to know
when's the right timing to go into
europe how which you know not really a
big part of the conversation today we're
talking all the time about the u.s
market and it's not a big part yet uh
surprisingly by the way also in europe
when you have a franchise
we have a french company called aircall
they're not as conversant about germany
as you'd think right because yeah i mean
everyone sees their own world and the us
so we managed to find this uh happy
place where
investors of our own fund right our lps
yeah and their network and their
constituents are our best friends when
it comes to taking our companies to the
market helping them kind of lubricate a
little bit of the processes that
typically take you know years and and
different languages different uh
geographies so we help with that and
that's useful even in the early stages
because as you said many of the young
entrepreneurs and the non-young
entrepreneurs um are
kind of waking up to that realization
that the european market has been
neglected right right and many of the
ceos and and the cross in their
portfolio have not spent much time
thinking about europe so that's that's
how we create and and manage a
conversation in a very early stage even
if we are not investing at that point
right and the occasional kind of moment
where a company is exactly at this
transition moment and we're able to
invest while they're going to europe
that's awesome and that's actually how
we've done most of our our investments
what is the risk the initial reception
that your founders may have especially
the first time entrepreneurs this is the
first time perhaps that growth investors
are are going to either approach them or
start looking at what they're doing and
do you want to build this relationship
are they receptive to it are they
hesitant
are they happy sad
so obviously not said they'd be worried
yeah so i think first entrepreneurs are
created uh in very different ways and
not all creators
all of them have the same reception
towards different types of messages but
a typical
entrepreneur founder ceo would probably
uh say oh the name rings the belt sounds
familiar you know we used to have the
deutsche the name now it's just a d
where i can go by the acronym but still
i think we're still affiliated or
associated in people's minds with
germany which is not bad and that would
actually
ring a bell sometimes and ring a bell
not in the ipo sense of things though it
does help
it will remind people that we are
different
and that you might be able to bring
strategic value now when people talk
about strategic investment they always
say oh you're a strategic investor right
what does that actually mean what does
that mean okay so first who is strategic
to whom right when you say are you a
strategic investor means are you
investing for someone's strategy like a
deutsche telekom strategy or you know
size or skt right
no it's the opposite think of it as the
entrepreneur am i strategic to you right
so instead of strategic investment
that's actually great my strategy is to
expand into europe you are helping me
with that hence you're strategic to me
reversing the rules a little bit sure
and the other thing is obviously um
money right we are able to write bigger
and bigger checks we're raising a new
fund it's going to be a bigger fund
checks are going to grow
that's not a consideration for most
entrepreneurs but being able to get get
a double digit million check from a
strategic investor that helps you with
with something different is unique
in the past it used to be the those
smaller you know those large investors
that are strategically coming with
smaller checks probably don't move the
needle right so you need to want them a
lot now we can actually cater to your
financial needs and make your rounds you
know scale sure with bigger checks and
still bring that strategic value that
you imagine as the entrepreneur if
you're looking at your position within
the firm as a partner and you obviously
have hands and legs in all various all
various positions especially as you're
talking you know so intentionally about
value creation the way that you're
creating these relationships with
companies and
being very data driven and trying to be
very analytical about it while also
being you know i'm sure very
relationship driven by what's happening
what i enjoy most i mean you're doing
there's so many different things you do
what what which part really resonates
with the guy horowitz
well so guy horowitz the original guy
horowitz uh not even the musician guy is
a product guy right
yeah so for me uh if we offer a product
to the customers the constituents which
are the startups uh that is unique and
of high quality and consistently so
we're gonna do well right so our best
ambassadors are our own entrepreneurs
and founders and yeah the boardwork is
interesting but i do not imagine the
case where i'm the most experienced guy
on the board you know i've been doing
this for 20 years now there are people
with double the gray hair or less hair
but all gray
yeah and you know people that have seen
more ipos and more downturns i'm
learning all the time and improving all
the time that holds true for any of us
as board members as gps in the fun where
we excel
is where we bring unique value and
that's around that kind of ability to go
to market and touch it in a different
way and that's our product market fit
especially nowadays with with growth
stage companies right that's exactly
what they need the next 50 million
that's not going to come from the super
crowded market here in the us so that's
what i enjoy the most that's by the way
where we get the most echo so when
people talk about us they don't talk
about our great uh uh
you know whatever uh off sites yeah or
uh investor meetings we do great ones as
well but that's like anyone else you
know when we open the door and someone
goes through it and gets a deal done
that's actually that resonance
i want you to take me back a long time
before the tcp
and before the army even
before guy the entrepreneur you know
middle school elementary school you know
you're walking down the street you're
walking to school what what interests
you what is what what really sparks your
curiosity
right so i'm you know i'm a a missed
architect right a missed architect yeah
yeah or a card designer i mean the two
things that i would fill my notebooks
with and i was a pretty boring really
bored student in middle school right
people who remember me from those days
remember my notes being filled with wow
yeah
all sorts of things right so cars
when i saw tesla for the first time i
think year was uh the tesla s right when
did the concert about 12 13 years ago i
was like you went back to the noble
consumer yeah that's fine that's mine my
design uh
unfortunately they didn't even buy the
stock right now so uh for me every every
building
every uh car everything that's like a
combination of art and science you know
design engineering meets art
that that makes me kind of you know
want to do it then what better place to
do it this interview from the empire
state building oh absolutely i mean i
still remember that uh
you know movie that i saw as a young kid
where i saw the emperor still doing for
the first time was like such a perfect
piece of architecture i love it if i
would ask any of your partners any of
your band members any of your
entrepreneurs who is guy what words come
to mind if they think of guy horowitz
what do you think they would say
okay i'll try to make this uh
interesting i mean i can say lots of
things that would probably reflect on my
my ego right you know dreamer i think
i'm a dreamer you know for me you know
keeping my dream
alive
uh while doing all those things that are
the the brick and mortar the bread and
butter i think you know dreaming is is
part of who i am or maybe a very big
part of who i am i love it
i really appreciate it this is
so amazing for me hey i'm i i still
follow your music i was listening to
your songs on on my walk here
from times square and and i just love
your work and i and it's just very
clever and and i'm personally inspired
by the idea of of pursuing the passion
while also working extremely hard and
then finding the ways in which the way
we pursue the passion actually
intersects with what with what we're
doing in our day-to-day and and the way
that within dtcp you're thinking about
the relationships you're forming with
with the entrepreneurs when it may not
be the right time yet but you're
understanding that it's going to get
there and then you want to be their
value created creation partners and
strategic partners
and obviously with the world opening up
and thinking about europe i think it's a
amazing opportunity so thank you very
much no thank you you might want to turn
the camera off because i'm getting
emotional so thank you